eu não comecei a correr para emagrecer
eu não comecei a correr pra parar de
fumar para parar de beber
eu comecei a correr pela sensação de
liberdade
eu vou falar uma coisa que eu tenho que
ter coragem a falar ea corrida me deu
essa coragem
vocês não sabem e os pais
ai mãe não sabem o mal que eles causam
que a briga deles causam nos filhos
principalmente nas crianças é uma
sensação de pânico como se fosse uma
sensação de morte
meus pais brigavam muito quando eu era
pequena eu tinha todos esses sintomas
era uma sensação de insegurança de que
você não podia fazer nada para resolver
aquilo eu tinha mais ou menos uns 18
anos e meus pais
quebraram um mega paulo a primeira coisa
que me veio na cabeça foi que eu vou
fugir
eu saí correndo descalça do morumbi até
o edifício itália mais ou menos uns 10
quilômetros e nesse percurso eu senti
todas as sensações que uma pessoa possa
sentir eu senti medo eu chorei eu rezei
eu agradeci
eu senti dor várias vezes eu pensei em
parar mas aquele vento batendo no meu
rosto e aquela sensação de liberdade me
fez continuar porque eu também sentir
coisas muito boas
é como se eu tivesse resolvido naquela
hora eu me curei eu comecei a fazer
planos eu tive idéia eu sonhei
eu sonhei com uma vida livre de qualquer
tipo de violência
e quando eu cheguei no edifício itália
onde eu era estagiário e bater a mão na
parede era uma coluna gerar gelada de
granito aquela sensação de morte passou
a ser uma sensação de vida ea corrida se
tornou a minha melhor amiga
eu não sabia que a corrida tinha
empoderado porque naquela época a gente
não falava e empoderamento
era uma sensação boa que aliviou o meu
pânico
meus pais não pararam de brigar mas eu
também não parei de correr e foi a
melhor coisa que eu fiz na minha vida
sabem por que eu resolvi ser promotora
de justiça e há 13 anos eu atendo casos
graves de violência principalmente de
violência contra a mulher e eu acabei
adquirindo uma sensibilidade um
conhecimento da mulher que eu atendo pra
sentir a dor do tapa que ela leva pra
sentir o medo da ameaça para sentir
vergonha quando ela é abusada
sexualmente
ou ela sofre algum tipo de assédio e eu
preciso me manter com saúde física tratá
lá todos os dias pronta para o que der e
vier e eu preciso ter também uma saúde
mental para não cometer nenhum tipo de
injustiça
hoje eu atua em praticamente seis mil
processos de crimes violentos contra a
mulher
além disso eu desenvolvo quatro grandes
projetos de capacitação de mulheres o
empoderamento feminino atendimento de
vítimas de violência contra a mulher e
conscientização dos homens que estão
respondendo processos que são agressores
de mulheres
além disso eu sou mãe tenho três filhos
um adolescente no segundo casamento tem
o ex marido e uma vida social a fim não
das mais boas mas tem alguma coisinha
social e submetida atleta e as pessoas
me perguntam como você consegue a
resposta um correndo se dá tudo certo eu
corro pra agradecer eu corro pra
comemorar
e para buscar novas idéias novos
objetivos nota novas metas
se der tudo errado eu corro também dessa
vez não mais pra fugir para buscar
soluções
hoje eu afirmo que a corrida nem
poderoso e quando você se empoderar pela
corrida ou por qualquer outra coisa que
você se identifica coisas maravilhosas
acontecem na sua vida você se sente mais
bonita mais forte
autonomia para tomar decisões para mudar
de idéia se você quiser e ninguém tem
nada a ver com isso
você começa a ter planos metas sonhos e
transfere isso para a sua vida pessoal e
para a sua vida profissional
você fica mais resistente eu já pensei
até em ser presidente da república é
coisa mais empoderadas do que isso e já
que a gente está falando empoderamento
já que a gente está falando
empoderamento pra mim não é se está em
poderá da desculpa não é ser empoderada
estar empoderada porque hoje em dia as
mulheres se cobra mas eu tenho que será
empoderada eu tenho que ser em poderá
ter situações que você não é
imponderável que você não tá empoderada
mas você tem que ter mecanismos e fontes
pra buscar esse empoderamento tem horas
que eu me sinto a empoderada e não é um
traço da minha personalidade é um
comportamento momentâneo
tem horas que eu me sinto uma banana mas
também uma banana temporária porque eu
vou atrás de soluções
eu sei aonde buscar empoderamento as
pessoas os projetos de quem me aproximar
às vezes eu erro mas eu costumo acertar
mais do que errar
e quando você se empoderar quando a
mulher descobre uma fonte de
empoderamento quer exportar o poder que
todas nós temos é só despertar esse
poder
você tem a obrigação de compartilhar
esse empoderamento com alguém essa fonte
de empoderamento alguém com outras
mulheres principalmente inspire
compartilhe incentive pega na mão de uma
mulher que leva lá com você eu descobri
que a corrida nem poder ou sim
transformar a minha vida e se
transformou a minha vida e aliviou os
sintomas de pânico de medo de euforia de
ansiedade
ele vai ajudar outras mulheres também
vítimas de violência ou não
jovens que em vez de se enfiar na droga
no álcool no cigarro
vamos do esporte para buscar a sensação
de alívio que podem ter tido do
os problemas assim como eu tive e foi
assim que eu percebi que a corrida
poderia o poder a outras mulheres
desenvolve o projeto movimento pela
mulher cujo objetivo era incentivar as
mulheres no esporte
começando com prática de caminhada e
corrida o objetivo de chamar a atenção
das autoridades do grave problema da
violência contra a mulher porque nós
conseguimos reunir um número grande de
pessoas
chamar a atenção dos homens eles suarem
por nós na corrida e por fim conseguimos
juntar angariar fundos para investir em
ongs que trabalham com o empoderamento
feminino e atendimento às vítimas de
violência contra a mulher
no começo nós fizemos um treino de
corrida pequeno para 100 mulheres
esse treinamento para 300 mulheres
depois aumentou para 500 para mil para
duas mil as semana passada nós tivemos a
segunda corrida de rua
o movimento pela mulher igualdade
empoderamento e justiça e reunimos duas
mil pessoas no parque do ibirapuera
correndo juntos lado a lado pelo fim da
violência contra a mulher
a nossa corrida agora entrou para o
calendário oficial das corridas de rua
do município de são paulo aquela
sensação que eu tive
correndo descalça é deficitária
transformou num grande projeto para
todas nós pra todos nós porque eu
acredito no esporte como uma causa de
prevenção à violência contra a mulher a
mulher adquire a autoestima a mulher
adquire força a mulher adquire autonomia
a mulher adquire liberdade e o homem o
homem fica menos violento
vocês sabiam a uma pesquisa que diz da
casa da carolina do norte que quem
pratica 30 minutos de caminhada ou
corrida por dia têm uma diminuição de
83% da raiva e do stress
china quanto os conflitos não
diminuiriam que isso os homens que
praticam atividade física eles sabem
menos uso do álcool e da droga que são
fatores de risco de violência contra a
mulher
o senado federal aprovou uma lei que
elege o ano de 2016 como o ano do
empoderamento da mulher na política e no
esporte
só que o curioso é que 50% das mulheres
brasileiras em uma pesquisa divulgada
pela pelo ministério de de esportes de
2014 50% das mulheres brasileiras são
sedentárias
eu acho que as mulheres precisam ocupar
esses lugares também na sociedade é um
direito nosso
a lei maria da penha prevê no seu artigo
3º que toda mulher tem direito à vida
toda mulher tem direito à segurança à
saúde à moradia a convivência em família
há várias coisas e mais diz que tem
direito ao esporte
precisamos mudar esse jogo estão
preparadas
muitas pessoas me perguntam como começar
calçando tênis e dando o primeiro passo
com o pé direito por favor não é pra
começar a amiga sua louca louca da
corrida não é pra começar caminhando
caminhando correndo correndo mais um
pouquinho eu comecei a minha primeira
prova de corrida de cinco quilômetros
depois aumentei para 10
aumentei para 21 quilômetros fiz uma
maratona e cheguei a fazer até uma prova
de 100 quilômetros
hoje em dia até o final do ano eu estou
inscrita em mais seis provas de rua uma
meia maratona uma maratona e uma prova
de aventura
meu marido acabou de descobrir a priori
como confidencial
e nós não vamos desistir porque se a
mulher começa muito rápido
ou ela se machuca ou ela desiste e aí eu
trago para vocês um recado da própria
maria da penha e ela diz o seguinte eu
maria da penha
lutei 19 anos e seis meses por justiça e
não parei
não é agora que vocês vão parar é eu
quero que vocês saiam daqui hoje com o
firme propósito ou com o conhecimento de
uma fonte de inspiração e de
empoderamento que é o esporte
eu quero que vocês se inspirem em
homenagem a vocês e o mês internacional
da mulher
eu quero apresentar exemplos de mulheres
que transformaram e transformam a vida
delas com a corrida e deixar pra vocês
negado ou vários legados o legado da
resiliência andré livre foi atropelada
enquanto ela corria treinava para a sua
maratona
ela ficou três meses sem andar e oito
meses sem poder correr amanhã ela
embarca para paris para correr a sua
primeira maratona o legado da saúde a
filomena fumou por 42 anos e com a
corrida ela conseguiu parar de fumar
hoje ela completa um ano cinco meses e
23 dias sem fumar e uma economia de
aproximadamente três mil e cem reais em
comprar cigarro
o legado da juventude
a gabriela a gabriela correu a sua
primeira prova de cinco quilômetros na
nossa corrida movimento pela mulher e
ainda fez uma homenagem às mulheres e
postou no instagram o legado do ânimo
a doutora ivete se inspirou nas corridas
de rua e montou um grupo de corrida da
terceira idade na cidade tiradentes
o legado da determinação a edna era o
workaholic de um tempo no trabalho para
se dedicar à família
mas a mesma energia que ela tinha no
trabalho ela se dedicou para corrida e
hoje é uma das nossas melhores
corredoras da maior equipe de de corrida
de rua do brasil
o legado da superação
alegou betty era corredora ela teve
câncer de mama e superou com dignidade
sessões de quimioterapia e radioterapia
e hoje tem no currículo dela 10
maratonas o legado do sonho
duas meninas que treinam duro todos os
dias na comunidade e tem o sonho de
serem atletas olímpicas legal do café
bayern munique harmonique além de ser
mãe é médica e ela busca na corrida à
saúde necessária para incentivar tanto
os alunos dela quanto as outras irmãs e
todas as pessoas que ela tem de café
harter em qualidade de vida
a corredora
o legado da força a caminhada começou a
correr pra emagrecer mas ela descobriu
na corrida que ela tinha hipertensão e
como era muito jovem
ninguém ia descobrir que ela sofria
disso hoje com a corrida ela consegue
controlar a hipertensão dela e ainda
arranjou um namorado triatleta um legado
da transformação
o iphone iphone era dar uma vida
desregrada
ela bebia fumava vivia na balada
mas um dia ela resolveu se transformar e
todo dia ela comemora hoje que ela é uma
9 vôlei e eu sigo à risca do legado da
vida a daniela era corredora sofreu um
acidente de carro e ficou tetraplégica
com a corrida ela conseguiu voltar a
mexer os braços hoje ela é a primeira
atleta para tetraplégica do brasil e
atleta do desafio
o legado da felicidade com a yara
aí acabou em fazer 50 anos mas ela não
quer que falharam os novos 40 ela quer
que fale que são os novos 50 porque é
com essa energia essa felicidade que a
corrida proporcionou que ela quer ser
vista
um delegado da pf estética a christ um
sonho ser atleta olímpica mas ela não
teve apoio financeiro não desistiu se
transformou numa atleta de elite e hoje
ela ganha quase todas as provas de
corrida de rua de são paulo
o legado da inspiração a neide sofreu
todos os tipos de violência que uma
mulher pode sofrer mas ela teve coragem
para enfrentar buscou empoderamento na
corrida não só pra ela como empoderou
400 mulheres da comunidade do capão
redondo e enfim a nossa embaixadora que
é o legado que o legado da liberdade a
laurinha correu na semana passada os
seus primeiros cinco quilômetros e que
sejam os primeiros de muito para nós
mulheres é muito mais difícil desistir
do que em frente
não somos todas iguais respeitando as
nossas diversidades de uma coisa eu
tenho certeza
somos todas vencedora